- [Instructor] We're
told that two contestants
are finalists in a cooking competition.
For the final round,
each of them spin a wheel
to determine what star
ingredient must be in their dish.
I guess the primary ingredient,
and we can see it could be chard, spinach,
romaine lettuce, I'm guessing,
cabbage, arugula, or kale.
And so then they give us these
different types of events,
or at least the symbols for
these different types of events,
and then give us their meaning.
So K-sub 1 means, the first
contestant lands on kale,
K-sub 2 means, the second
K-sub 1 with this superscript C,
which you could view as complement.
So K-sub 1 one complement,
the first contestant
does not land on kale.
So it's the complement of
this one right over here.
And then K-sub 2 complement,
would be that the second
contestant does not land on kale.
So the not of K-sub 2 right over here.
Using the general multiplication rule,
express symbolically the probability
that neither contestant lands on kale.
So pause this video and see
if you can have a go at this.
All right, so the general
multiplication rule
is just saying this notion
that the probability
of two events, A and B,
is going to be equal
to the probability of,
let's say A given B, times
the probability of B.
Now, if they're independent events,
if the probability of A occurring
does not depend in any way
on whether B occurred or not,
then this would simplify to
this probability of A given B,
would just become the probability of A.
And so if you have two independent events,
you would just multiply their probability.
So that's just all they're talking about,
the general multiplication rule.
But let me express
what they're actually
asking us to express.
The probability that neither
contestant lands on kale.
So that means that this
is going to happen,
the first contestant
does not land on kale,
and this is going to happen,
the second contestant
does not land on kale.
So I could write it this way.
The probability that K-sub 1 complement
and K-sub 2 complement, and
I could write it this way.
This is going to be equal to,
we know that these are independent events
because if the first contestant gets kale
or whatever they get it,
it doesn't get taken out of the running
for the second contestant.
The second contestant still
has an equal probability
of getting or not getting kale,
regardless of what happened
for the first contestant.
So that means we're just in the situation
where we multiply these probabilities.
So that's gonna be the
probability of K-sub 1 complement,
times the probability
of K-sub 2 complement.
All right, now let's do part two.
Interpret what each part
of this probability statement represents.
So I encourage you like always,
pause this video and
try to figure that out.
All right, so first let's think
about what is going on here.
So this is saying,
the probability that this
is K-sub 1 complement.
So the first contestant
does not land on kale.
So first, first contestant
does not get kale,
and, I'll write and in caps,
and second contestant does get kale.
And second does get kale.
So that's what this left-hand is saying.
And now they say that that
is going to be equal to,
so this part right over here,
probability that the first
contestant does not get kale.
Probability that first does not get kale,
times, right over here.
And the second part right over here
is the probability that the
second contestant gets kale,
given that the first
contestant does not get kale.
So probability that the second gets kale,
given, that's what this vertical
line right over here means,
it means given, shorthand for given.
Given, I wrote it up there too.
Given that first does not get kale.
And we're done, we've just
explained what is going on here.